I'm sure you've heard of Chris Hinshaw's
old man balance test where you put your
shoes on on one oh this is great
everyone you're welcome everyone
listening should do this test and he
actually created it um so that he would
have something to compete against his
kids and win and so uh the idea is you
put your socks and shoes on the floor
and you stand on one leg and you reach
down and grab your sock and you put on
your sock without putting that foot down
and then you reach down and grab your
shoe and put your shoe on and tie it and
then you switch and do it on the other
side and it's a really great two minute
balance practice and that's how I put my
shoes on every single day you know and
that's just this little you know small
behavior that that we add into our day
that's easy and fun and you can you know
challenge your kids to do it and so you
know that's just one of those things
that we've snuck in and said hey there
are ways that you can change your
environment and just slightly think
about your environment differently so
that these are just things you do
without having to rely on Willpower or
motivation